for those of you who are curious and
have a little bit of a background in
calculus I thought I would do a very
optional and when I say it's optional
you don't have to understand this in
order to progress with the economics
playlist but a very optional proof
showing you that in general the slope of
the marginal revenue curve for a
monopolist is twice the slope of the
demand curve assuming that the demand
curve is aligned so the demand curve
looks like that this is price this is
quantity that is demand right over there
I'm going to show that the marginal
revenue curve has twice the slope it is
twice as steep as this and it's really
twice the negative slope so let me just
write price as a function of quantity we
know we get price since this is a line
we can essentially write it in our
traditional slope y-intercept form and
in algebra class you would write if this
was Y and this was X you would write y
is equal to MX plus b where m is the
slope and B is the y-intercept I'll do
something very similar but instead of Y
and X we have P and Q so if P is equal
to M times Q where m is the slope plus
plus the p-intercept
plus B so this right over here is B and
if you were to if you were to take your
if you were to take take your change in
P if you were to take your change in P
and divide it by your change in Q your
change in Q you would get M that is your
slope change in P divided by change in Q
now what is going to be our total
revenue and this is kind of we're just
kind of almost doing what we've done in
the last few videos but we're doing it
in general terms so this is total
revenue total revenue as a function of
quantity
well total revenue is just price times
quantity total revenue is just price
times quantity we've already written
we've already written price as a
function of quantity right over here so
we could take that and substitute it and
substitute it in right over there so we
get total revenue is equal to and I'll
write it all in blue we have M Q plus B
and then we're going to multiply that
times Q we're going to multiply that
times Q or we get total revenue is
equal to M Q squared M Q squared plus B
times Q and this is a parabola and it's
actually going to be a downward sloping
parabola because M is going to be
negative this is downward sloping M is
it has a negative slope so M is negative
so we know we know that M is less than
zero over here that's one of the
assumptions we'll make if M is less than
zero this is going to be a
downward-opening parabola total revenue
will look something totally
revolutionize just the derivative and
this is the calculus part it's the slope
of the tangent line at any given point
and that is what the derivative is it's
the slope of the tangent line at any
point as a function as a function of
quantity so you give me a quantity I
will tell you what the slope of the
tangent line of the total revenue
function is at that point so we
essentially just have to take the
derivative of this with respect to Q so
we get D total revenue over DQ so how
much does total revenue change with a
very very small change in quantity and
infinitely small infinitesimal change in
quantity and this comes straight out of
calculus M is a constant Q squared the
derivative of Q squared with respect to
Q is 2q so it's going to be 2 Q times
the constant so it's going to be 2 m 2m
Q and then B is a constant width we're
assuming it's given B is a constant the
derivative of BQ with respect to Q is
just going to be B it's just going to be
B and so right over here this is our
marginal revenue curve or I used to say
our marginal revenue line it is 2m Q
plus B so notice it has the same
y-intercept as our demand curve so it
definitely starts right over there but
it has twice the slope the slope of our
demand curve is M the slope of our
marginal revenue curve is 2 M is 2 m and
this is a negative slope so this will be
twice as negative so it will look
something like this
we'll look something like this just like
that so no matter what your demand curve
is if it's a few sumit sad out if you
assume it's a line like this the
marginal revenue curve will be a line
with twice the slope and in this case is
twice the negative slope which is kind
of what's going to be generally true
anyway if you understood that great you
now feel good that this is always the
case for a linear demand curve like this
if you did not understand it don't worry
you can proceed with the economics
playlist you don't need that know
calculus
for for this for this playlist